l'actualité de ce 9 avril c'est aussi ce
chiffre que vous allez découvrir 1
million c'est le montant de l'enveloppe
budgétaire consacré par le Conseil
Général des ivelines au needidpool
l'hiver a été rude il a plutôt tendance
à s'éterniser de nombreuses dégradations
ont été causées sur les routes du
département des réparations temporaires
ont été faites pour maintenir la
sécurité mais les véritables travaux ne
débuteront qu'au cours des prochaines
semaines dès le retour du beuton 27000
m² de surface de chaussée sont concernés
par ces travaux 1 million d'euros qui
sont budgetés par le Conseil Général des
iblines